Hi, I'm Erik Voss and there's a new
trailer for Game of Thrones Season 7,
which is crazy because I feel like I'm
still recovering from the first trailer
a few weeks ago. Like, give me some air,
HBO. I'm just kidding, smother me
HBO! Smother me with Game of Thrones
footage! This second trailer has even
more interesting shots, and details that
you might have missed, little clues that could
predict what's going down in season 7. So,
spoiler warning: If you don't want to get
into any of that stuff, seriously, some of
our predictions have been weirdly right
in the past, and if we are, some of these
could end up being pretty huge spoilers.
So you've been warned. Anyway, let's get
started.
"Don't fight in the north.
Or the south. Fight every battle, everywhere.
Always, in your mind."
So this trailer opens with the amazing
music called Light of the Seven, which is the
same music that we heard open the season
6 finale, Winds of Winter. Now this music
was composed by Ramin Djawadi, but the
director that episode, Miguel Sapochnik,
actually consulted on the dramatic
shifts of this music, so the music alone
tells a story, carefully leading each
character closer and closer to their
deaths. And just like it did in that
episode, this music says the same thing
in this trailer ,with Sansa now filling
in for Cersei as the badass queen,
turning back towards the camera as every
other character confronts death. And if
you're interested in this stuff, the
Light of the Seven has even more secret
narrative elements that we broke down in
our season finale video last summer. Also
Djawadi's music is just always super
layered and interesting from a narrative
standpoint, and he used a lot of these
similar techniques in the last trailer,
and you should definitely check out our
breakdown for that, too. Now, what is Santa
doing here? It looks like she's in the
godswood in Winterfell, walking away from
the heart tree, and if you look closely
there's a figure standing behind her.
Actually this could be a reverse shot of
the scene that we saw in the Winds of
Winter, when she walked away from
Littlefinger. And that might be why we
hear Baelish's voice here, giving Sansa
advice. He's saying not to focus on one
geographic region of the war, but to look
at the big picture like a chessboard,
thinking twelve moves ahead. In fact this
game board motif, with various compass
directions, is another parallel to how
the first trailer began. "Enemies to the
East. Enemies to the West. Enemies to the South. Enemies to the North." Now this trailer as
an entire piece opens and closes with
Sansa, who we don't really see anywhere
else in the trailer, and I think there's
a really important reason for that, but
I'll save it for the end of the video. In
the meantime, there's just so much more
to talk about, so let's move on.
Okay, so in this section we see the
northern gate of Castle Black open, which
is from the last trailer, but now we see
who it's opening for. Looking at this
closely, that's Meera dragging Bran on
the sled. So this is confirmation that
Bran will finally return south of the
wall, probably to Winterfell, too - as we see
later in this trailer. But remember the
mark that the Night King left on Bran's
arm allowed the White Walkers to break
through the protective magical barrier
around the great weirwood tree way up
north, and that might also apply to the
magical barrier that's supposed to be in
the wall to keep White Walkers out. So, do
you think Bran crossing under the wall
is something that could doom the wall?
Let me know in the comments. But then,
moving on, we see Jon in wildling furs
somewhere north of the wall probably, and
then we get this shot in King's
Landing. Notice the castle towers in the
background, as crimson Lannister banners
hang down.
So clearly Cersei has redecorated the
city from Baratheon insignia to
Lannister lion like she did in the
throne room in the last trailer,
replacing the seven pointed star with a
lion. But notice here how the citizens of
King's Landing are clapping. And take a
look at these soldiers. So who are these
guys? They aren't wearing white
Kingsguard capes or red Lannister armor,
so it's hard to tell, but I think these
guys might be Euron Greyjoy's soldiers.
They don't look exactly like they did at
the Kingsmoot last season, but their
armor and helmets are similar colors to
the sails on the Greyjoy boat. So why
would Euron's men be celebrated in
King's Landing?
Well in my last trailer breakdown, I looked
closely at that shot in the throne room
with Cersei talking to someone who kind
of grossed her out, and I suggested that
that could be Euron Greyjoy offering
to use the fleet to protect King's
Landing, probably in exchange or
something that Cersei wouldn't want to
give. But my theory is that because
Cersei is out of allies, she would be
forced to make this kind of alliance. Now
we get further confirmation of that
prediction later in the trailer, but here
I think this is Euron's men returning to
King's Landing with the people of the city
thanking them for protecting it from sea.
But let me know in the comments who you
think these soldiers are, and if you
think there's anything to this theory of
an alliance between Euron and Cersei. And
before I move on, there is this shot of
Daenerys at Dragonstone running her hand
along the Westeros map table created by
her ancestor, Aegon the conquerer. So as I
pointed out in the last trailer
breakdown, this could be Daenerys showing
that she's poised
to repeat that conquest. And notice how
most of the pieces are already knocked over,
except this one, which looks like it
could be the same Lannister lion piece
that we saw get knocked over in the last
trailer, and I think Daenerys pausing
here is her reaching out to do that.
Maybe to signal her desire to take
Cersei off the Iron Throne?
Or her desire to attack the Lannisters
home at Casterly Rock and Lannisport?
More on that later, but let's move on.
"For centuries our families fought together,
against their common enemy. Despite their
differences. Together." Okay starting off
this section, there's this shot of the
beaches of Dragonstone, and it's hard to
tell, but the tiny figures arriving by
boat look like they could be Jon and
Sir Davos and their crew. And if look even
further behind them, you can barely make
out a 3-person greeting party, which
could be Tyrion, Varys, maybe Grey worm,
maybe Daenerys herself? And so this
could be part of Jon and Sir Davos'
diplomatic mission to Dragonstone to try
to get Daenerys to join them in their
fight against the White Walkers. Next,
this shot of Arya on horseback, and based
on her facial expression here, it looks
like she could be coming up the hill to
see her home of Winterfell. Like, the
camera is gonna pan around to show the
Winterfell towers as she finally makes
this dramatic homecoming. Then, after this
shot of Jamie in King's Landing, and a
shot of Littlefinger, and a blade
sharpening from the last trailer, there's
this interesting image of Daenerys
walking along the Dragonstone beach. Now
this could be Daenerys walking out to
greet Jon, or shortly after she
arrives home, but check out the shape in
the red-colored rock formation behind
her. It kind of looks like the head of
Drogon. And it would be super awesome if
this shot is Daenerys meeting Jon, and
then the camera pans over and we see
Jon is standing in front of a rock
formation that's in the shape of a
wolf's head? Or hell, maybe in the shape
of another dragon, now that we know that
John is half Targaryen? Now there are
actually a lot of interesting
consequences of Jon's Targaryen bloodline
that the show might explore, and I go
into all of them, including his claim to
the Iron Throne, and what his real name
is, in another video I made about the
unresolved mysteries left to do on Game
of Thrones. So go check that out. Now over
this, notice the speech that Jon gives.
"For centuries our families fought
together.
Against a common enemy." Now the editing
makes it seem like he's talking to
Daenerys here, like this is part of his
pitch to join his mission, but when you
stop to think about it, the last fight
that Jon is talking about is the war
that the northern families joined forces
together against Daenerys' Targaryen
family. So this audio is probably Jon
talking to the other northern Lords. It's
just ironic that we see one of the
losers of that war, Daenerys, as Jon is
alluding to it. Now this banner that
Daenerys tears down is a stag
emblazoned with a flaming heart. And remember
that's the sigil of Stannis Baratheon,
who took Dragonstone from the Targaryens
and then later abandoned it when he
sailed north to join Jon at the wall. And I think this shot with the banner is
meant to parallel Jon's homecoming in
Winterfell after the Battle of the
bastards, when they finally tore down the
banners of the strangers who took over
their ancestral home and replaced them
with the natural Stark banners. So I
think Daenerys is doing the same here,
reclaiming her ancestral home from the
people who took it from her. And before I
move on, we see this amazing wide shot of
Daenerys' three dragons flying toward
Dragonstone, while Tyrion stands on the
cliff
looking a little nervous. I actually have a
prediction about what's going on here,
but I'll get to it later. For now, let's
move on. "We need to do the same if we're gonna survive. Because
the enemy is real."
Okay after this quick shot of Theon as
he stands on what looks like a ship on
fire, more on that in a second, we get
this interesting shot of Grey worm on a
different boat headed into this cave. Now
I think this cave could be a secret back
entrance to Casterly Rock, and here's why
I think this: Tyrion told Varys that his
father, Tywin, put him in charge of the
sewer system of Casterly Rock.
"My father put me in charge of all the
drains and systems in Casterly Rock. The water
never flowed better, and all the sh*t
found its way to the sea." Now that means
that Tyrion probably knows all the
drainage routes underneath the city, and
I think that he's going to share this
knowledge with Grey worm and the
unsullied so that they can sneak a small
task force into the city and sack it from
the inside out. Actually, remember Grey
worm took down the city of Yunkai in
a similar mission in season 3. Next,
there's a shot at Brienne and Podrick
returning to Winterfell, and a very quick
shot of the Hound, Sandor Clegane,
somewhere probably way up north. Now,
remember he joined up with the
Brotherhood last season, so it's looking
like he and the Brotherhood will be the
ones joining Jon in this mission north
of the wall that we've seen clips of in
these trailers. We also see more shots of
this big battle, which I'm assuming is
all from the same Battle of Daenerys'
forces against the Lannisters. First,
there's this shot of an unsullied
soldier going down in a barrage of
arrows fired by these Lannister archers,
and notice how Jaime and Bronn are the
ones commanding them. So that means Jaime
will be part of this battle. The same
battle, remember, that will feature a
massive dragon, and I just can't wait to
see the look on Jamie's face when that
thing shows up. There's also a quick shot
of the moment that the Dothraki
Calvary collides with the Lannister
shields, and yeah, I assume some CGI went
into this shot, because they're not going
to like Ram real horses into real people
and shields. So when you think about that,
I love the detail of the splinters
exploding. There's also a quick angle of
this ship on fire with someone jumping
onto the deck, and yeah, again I think
this is part of that naval battle
between Yara and Theon's forces and Euron's
fleet. Next, there's this shot of a
flock of crows flying over what looks
like a massive army of wights and white
walkers. And check out this crow's eye -
he's clearly being warged into by Bran
here, so maybe this is the three-eyed
Raven's promise coming true and Bran is
finally flying here.
"You'll never walk again, but you will fly."
Now it's interesting that the Night King
seems to look up at Bran here. Like he's
able to see through the warg and spot
Bran. And of course, that's what scares
Bran out of the vision. Now this could
be the mark that the Night King left on
Bran, making him visible to the Night
King again. And before I move on, Bran
wakes up sitting in this wheelchair,
which looks very similar to one that
prince Doran Martell had. It actually kind
of feels like Bran is Professor X coming
out of cerebro, but in this case the
cerebro is the heart tree of the
Winterfell godswood. That's right! Bran is
finally home! And who is he talking to
here? Now first I thought this was Sir
Davos, who's maybe like asking Bran for
information on how far south the White
Walkers are, and by the way, there's
actually a super interesting theory
about where the White Walkers are headed
and what they want, and I go into all
those details in our other Game of
Thrones unresolved mysteries video, so
definitely check that out. But I'm
wondering if this guy isn't Sir Davos,
but it's another character. Now currently
on the show, Bran is the only character
who definitely knows that Jon's true
parents are Lyanna Stark and Rhaegar
Targaryen, except one other person:
Howland Reed.
Now Howland Reed is Meera's father and he
was there with Ned Stark at the Tower of
Joy, so maybe when Bran returns to
Winterfell with Meera, Howland will
arrive and confirm with Bran what
exactly it was that he saw. So do you
think Howland Reed will appear on Game of
Thrones?
Let me know what you think in the
comments, but let's move on. so always
'It's always been real."
Okay, this next section starts with the
craziest shot in this trailer.
The Lightning Lord of the Brotherhood
without banners holding a flaming sword.
Now, we've seen him with a sword on fire
before, remember back in season 3 when he
dueled with the Hound, but this one looks
like it lights up on its own. Now this is
huge.
Obviously it connects Beric to the
prophecy of Azor Ahai reborn. Now
remember that figure is supposed to
carry a flaming sword and vanquish the
others, or the White Walkers. Now, I'm not
a hundred percent that this shot is
confirmation that Beric is Azor Ahai, but
we do know that he is a champion of the
Lord of Light, remember Thoros of Myr
did resurrect him from the dead the same
way that Melisandre did for Jon Snow. So
I do predict that Beric thinks he's
Azor Ahai reborn, and that that will be the
purpose of this small mission with Jon
and Tormund and the Brotherhood north of
the wall. I think they're on their way to
the White Walkers because they hope that
Beric will defeat them as Azor Ahai
is prophesied to. But because this is a
world created by George RR Martin, and I don't think he really cares about
prophecies that much, I really don't
think things will go down this neatly.
But what do you think about this? Do you
think this flaming sword makes Beric
Dondarrion the top candidate to be Azor
Ahai reborn and the prince that was
promised? Let me know in the comments. Up
next, we see these shots of Euron
Greyjoy's fleet making its way to King's
Landing. The sails have the Greyjoy
Kraken sigil and the side sails are the
same design that Euron's ships have in
the books. Now I think this is either part
of Euon's initial peaceful arrival to
King's Landing to form his alliance with
Cersei, or his post victory homecoming,
but more on that later.
We also see more shots of the unsullied
as they sack the city, and we see one
group of them opening the doors from the
inside, allowing more of them to pour in
from the outside. So here's what I think
is going down here: I think this will be
a part of a two-pronged attack. A smaller
task force sneaking into Casterly Rock
from the drains under the city, while
more are invading from the outside.
Actually I think that since we saw that
one unsullied soldier earlier on getting
hit by arrows fired from Lannister
arrows from behind their front lines, I
think it's possible that this whole
battle could be taking place outside the
city of Casterly Rock, with Jaime and
Bronn and the Lannisters defending their
home city. Now I could be wrong about this,
like this battle could just be taking
place somewhere else, or in a totally
different part of the season, but the
section does show us more parts of this
battlefield, wherever it is. Jamie
emotionally charging on horseback
through the flames, and another angle of
the closing shot from the last trailer
with the dragon flying overhead the Dothraki blood riders. And from this angle
you could make out that someone is
riding on the back of that dragon. Now my
first guess is obviously Daenaerys, but
it's kind of hard to tell which dragon
this is. Now I initially assumed it was
Drogon, the largest with black and red
scales, but it also kind of looks like
Rhaegal. That Dragon has greenish and red
scales, in which case maybe this isn't
Daenerys on the back of this dragon.
Maybe it's someone else, for example,
Tyrion. In fact, that could be what's
going on in that earlier shot with
Tyrion looking uncomfortable at
Dragonstone. Like, perhaps Daenerys is
ordering him to ride the dragon into
battle, because remember Tyrion was able
to get along pretty well with Rhaegal
back in Mereen, when he Unchained him.
And I know it seems like I'm kind of
grasping here, but if this is all true,
this would be a super emotional battle
for Tyrion, leading a deadly charge on
his home city, feeling like a traitor to
his Lannister men, specifically his
brother Jaime, the only Lannister he
still probably loves. This would be an
epic battle of brother against brother.
And if this is Tyrion riding Rhaegel, that
could just mean Daenerys divided her
forces, and that's actually a tactic used
by her ancestor, Aegon the conquerer. Very
rarely did he use all three dragons in one
battle, like usually he would send his
sisters on the other dragons to other
places. Because you really don't need
more than one dragon in a battle. So
maybe Daenerys has taken her other two
dragons somewhere else. Now of course
there's also the lingering mystery over
Tyrion's possible connection with the
dragons and the Targaryens, and I
discussed that in our other Game of
Thrones unresolved mystery video, so go
check it out, but for this video, let me
know in the comments - do you think that
we'll see Tyrion ever ride a dragon? And
do you want Tyrion to have to face his
brother Jaime in battle? Let me know.
Let's move on.
Okay, this section opens with Yara and
Theon nervously looking up at an
explosion on their ship, so yeah, things
are looking pretty bad for them in this
naval battle with their uncle Euron.
And I have a feeling that the way this
will go down is that maybe Yara and Theon
won't die here. But these trailers have
been showing us a lot of Yara and Theon in
this very dismal situation,
so honestly I'd be a little surprised if
this is actually the place they're going
to die. Rather I think this could go one
of two other ways, like maybe they
manage to escape. like they might be the
two figures that we saw plunge into the
water last trailer, or they could be
taken as hostages by Euron back to King's
Landing. I actually think that part of
the reason all those people in King's
Landing were clapping is that the
Greyjoy's brought some hostages back
with him, but if it's not Theon and Yara,
it could be someone else who's with them
in their fleet, and since we know that
there were a lot of people who were
teaming up with Daenaerys' fleet, including
the Tyrells and the Martels, I think it's
more likely that those hostages will be
Ellaria Sand and/or the sand snakes.
Remember they were the ones who killed
Cersei's daughter, Myrcella. So maybe
that's part of the alliance that Cersei
makes with Euron. Like she wants him to
bring her back the women who killed her
daughter. And maybe she wants to let the
mountain do a repeat of what Ellaria saw
him do to her boyfriend, Oberyn. Now these
next shots show the Lannister troops
getting into formation, and they're using
the same Spears through the shield tactic
that we saw the Boltons use in last
season's battle the bastards. Actually in
our breakdown of that episode, we explore
how that battle formation was inspired
by battles in real Roman history, so
definitely watch that video to see how
Game of Thrones uses these interesting
real-world battle history tactics to
inspire their battle scenes. But next is
this interesting shot of Jon Snow and
his men stranded on this rock surrounded
by wights. This kinda looks like another
nightmare hardhomle situation. And this
location looks a lot like the fist of
the first men that we've seen earlier in
the series. If you look closely at the background,
these wights are covering the mountain
sides like ants. Also if you look closely
over on the right, I think we can make
out the Night King sitting on this horse
flanked by a few other white walkers who
are watching all this go down. Now
fighting alongside Jon is Beric with
his flaming sword. Some people are saying
that looks more like the Hound, but
notice how this guy is wearing the same
high collar and fur
that Beric wore in that earlier shot. I
also assume that Tormund and the Hound
will also appear in the battle. Now a big
question here - how are Jon and his guys
supposed to get out of this impossible
situation?
Now unless we're seeing Jon's death here,
to me, the only way to get out of this is
some air support from above. Specifically,
maybe Daenerys and her dragons. Or maybe
one of the Dragons without Danny like
Viserion, the cream and gold colored one,
who I don't think we've seen alone
anywhere. I'm predicting that they might
swoop in and torch some of these wights,
remember fire is the only thing that
can kill them. Or maybe carry Jon to
safety like those great Eagles in the
Lord of the Rings. And there's a quick
shot of Missandei and Grey worm, and
then this interesting shot of someone
who looks like the Hound, but look closely at
this shot: he's not wearing any pants... or
just really short shorts. And this
location looks sunnier and warmer. I
don't think the Hound is in any location
like that. So this could be another one
of Bran's visions into the past, perhaps
showing the day that Sandor's face was
cruelly burned. Next is a shot of Jon
and Davos at Dragonstone. That rock wall
behind them is the same one from the
beach before; this could be their
reaction shot as Daenerys is coming up
to greet them. Now there's a quick shot
of Jon swinging his Valyrian steel sword,
Longclaw, at a white walker, Dothraki
riders galloping through flames, and then
this interesting shot of a beach. Now who
is this character collapsing weakly into
the water? Now it's kind of hard to tell,
but to me this guy kind of looks like
Gendry. Yeah I know, it's great! Gendry is
rumoured to come back this season. And
maybe he's just exhausted from rowing a
boat for three seasons. I don't know. Let
me know who you think this is in the
comments. Then after a shot of Euron
swinging at someone in this naval battle,
there's this freaky shot of Drogon and a
close-up of his teeth. And I'm pretty sure
that's Daenerys riding on his back and
that's Dragonstone in the background.
So this could be the point of view of
Tyrion, and this is the moment that, if my
theory is right, he and Daenerys split up
on the backs of different dragons. Okay,
let's move on to this final section.
"When the snows fall, and the white winds blow, the lone wolf dies,
but the pack survives."
Okay, so this final
section is super mysterious. First we see
this overhead shot that we saw in the last trailer. Now, I pointed out then that this
character is carrying a warhammer, which
remember was the weapon of choice of
Robert Baratheon. And that could mean
that this character is Robert's son, who
is an armory expert, Gendry. And this
might be proof that he'll join up with
the Brotherhood in this mission with
Jon and Tormund. We also see a shot of a
lone rider who looks like he's wounded
now this could be Jon escaping from
this battle with the white walkers. But
then, most interestingly, there's this
shot of Jon from behind as he faces off
with the wights.
now those flames in the background are
interesting. I would say they're from
Beric's sword, but everything is so
freakin' cold up in this location, I don't
know if this sword could have caused
those flames to get that high. So yeah, I'm
thinking that this is dragon fire from a
dragon that maybe picks them up and
saves them, and that dragon fire could be
why the wights are hanging back here. But
let's talk about Sansa's interesting
voice over here. "The lone wolf dies but
the pack survives. Now, a lot of you were asking
about this line about the lone wolf and
the pack, and it's actually a direct
quote from her father, Ned Stark, who said
the same line to Arya in the first book,
a Game of Thrones. This was when he was
trying to get her to stop fighting with
her sister, Sansa, basically trying to get
her to learn that Starks need to stick
together for when the darkness comes. And
this quote is something that comes back
to Arya throughout the books, actually.
She remembers it when she thinks Bran
and Rickon died when she's at Harrenhal,
and she remembers it at the beginning of
book four, believing now that Ned had
it's backwards.
And that her pack of Starks had all died
off, leaving her as the surviving lone
wolf. Now when Sansa says this line, we
don't see where she is or who she's
talking to, so maybe this is the line that she
tells Arya when they reunite, to call
back the time when they saw each other
when they were girls with this stupid
animosity, and now they've both grown older
and matured, and they understand how much
they need each other. But at the same
time, notice Sansa's dark tone as she says
these words."When the snows fall and the white
winds blow..."
Now the last time we heard Sansa talk
like this, it was last season at the end
of the Battle of the bastards when she
sentenced Ramsay Bolton to die. "Your words will disappear." So if
this is a similar kind of threat, who is
the lone wolf that Sansa is referring to?
Now I think this connects back to the
opening of this trailer, when
Littlefinger gave Sansa that advice.
"Fight every battle, everywhere. Always in
your mind." And looking back, those words
now kind of sound like final words
before someone dies. So yeah, I think
Sansa could be talking to Littlefinger
here. In a lot of ways, he's a lone wolf.
He's a solo operator, he doesn't really
rely on family or companions to get
stuff done. Also he's been trying to get
Sansa to turn against Jon, against her
own blood, to divide up the Stark pack,
and now it looks like the surviving
Stark kids are all reuniting in
Winterfell, and the pack has survived. So
I predict that Sansa is doing like a Sam
Jackson Bible verse in Pulp Fiction,
coldly invoking her father to avenge the
man who betrayed him, who is now trying
to turn his children against each other.
Finally putting an end to that game. But
who do you think Sansa is talking to
here? Who do you think is the lone wolf
that will die? Let me know your thoughts
on this question, and all the other
questions that I brought up throughout
this video. Comment down below and share
this video to keep the discussion going.
On Twitter, you can tweet directly at me
(@eavoss) or new rockstars (@newrockstars) and subscribe to this channel
to keep up with all the Game of Thrones
videos that we're going to be putting
out. You heard me,
we're putting out here at new rockstars.
You can also buy our love and really
just be a more active part of this
channel by contributing to new rockstars on patreon. Big thanks to all of
our current patrons, especially Kenny
Smith. Alright thanks for watching, bye.